In this section, we'll recap the logic created in the previous 205 class.
We'll examine the shortcomings of the previous system and adapt it to the new system designed
for increased modular functionality.
The previous system was built using a combination of triggers, level actors, and logic nested
within the level blueprint.
The process for activating the sequence would be adding a trigger box and a sequence actor
into the level, script the association between the actors via the level blueprint,
and finally trigger the sequence associated with that specific trigger.
While the system worked, the inherent downsides of this implementation were
1.
If we had multiple trigger box actors in our level, specifically targeting each trigger
box from the level actors would be very cumbersome and easily broken.
2.
The level blueprint contains the code needed to start the sequence.
This might not be an issue if we only use one level, however if we use more than one
level, we will need to copy and paste the code into each level's level blueprint.
This could lead to inconsistencies and functionality issues between levels.
And lastly, if we target our level actors rather than nesting our code within a standalone
blueprint, we will need to duplicate the level code for every actor that we want
to use for sequence activation.
The previous method of constructing code and logic for a sequence activation is perfectly
acceptable.
However, since this code and these systems will likely be used multiple times to trigger
many sequences, it would be far more efficient to migrate this code into a reusable standalone
actor.
We will do exactly that in the upcoming sections.